[Music]
welcome back and Hannity so earlier
today the President issued a tweet
reassuring Daka so-called dreamers
writing quote for all those daca that
are concerned about your status during
the six-month period you have nothing to
worry about no action now clearly
President Trump is trying to restore the
rule of law and the Constitution and not
usurp the powers of the legislative
branch but some Democrats they just
hell-bent on painting the president is
unhinged it never stops joining us now
the author of the 12 week bestseller
number one New York Times best seller
understanding Trump former Speaker of
the House Fox News contributor Newt
Gingrich who by the way also is
launching an early September in about a
week or so new online series entitled
defending America all right I want to
get to that in a second let me just stay
on the hurricane if I can for one minute
mr. speaker this is important you know
if the only thing the media can
criticize is Milania shoes and that's
basically all they had and you saw the
governor and you saw local officials and
you saw the federal government really
come together in an organized fashion
with next to zero complaints and I've
talked to people in Florida they are
working and coordinating in a similar
fashion there so I got to expect the
same results it doesn't that tell you
something about where people's mindset
is well I think the country is delighted
and encouraged that you could have
effective government that works and you
can have everybody state local federal
pulling in the same direction
you could have professional competence
as the president said a few minutes ago
you have people who are committed to
doing their job you have the American
military being mobilized this one-two
punch of Houston and Louisiana and now
Florida is probably as big a natural
disaster punch as we've had certainly in
my lifetime I feel it at a direct level
I have a daughter who lives in Florida
and she's right in the middle of this
and you know it's very sobering when you
look at the size of this storm and the
power but I think it is encouraging and
by the way let me just say on behalf of
the president I think part of the reason
he cut the deal he did yesterday on a
bipartisan basis to get
90 days funding and I think the Senate
actually has already moved today on this
he was trying to continue a momentum of
being together of doing something
together and of showing that the
American government can act quickly if
they can get the money out of Washington
to Houston this week setting the stage
by the way for potentially challenges
next week in Florida I think that's
another signal the American people that
maybe some things are coming together
and maybe President Trump who has a
natural background in construction and
in property and in looking at this sort
of thing
maybe he in fact is going to be able to
pull the country together the way they
came together in Texas you got a hope so
I look at this storm and I literally is
it it's chilling to see the cities that
will be impact the entire state is
engulfed by this hurricane this is going
to be as people are predicting could be
one of the worst storms ever you know
both of us are conservative we believe
in limited government greater freedom
more responsibility opportunity Society
and the federal government plays an
important role safety and security and
hopefully they don't get in the way of
prosperity which I would argue they
often do but isn't this one of the times
that government can really step up and
help people like in Texas like in
Florida and government work this time
it's nice to see it works occasionally
I'm not the biggest fan of it okay I
always try to remind people that the
founding fathers developed a
constitution for a limited but effective
government they didn't want a sloppy
government they didn't want an
incompetent government they wanted to be
limited in order to protect our freedom
and our privileges and our rights of
citizens but when they would have moved
they wanted to move very effectively
these were people who after all had
practiced for eight years
the art of war against the British
Empire they knew what it took to be
effective and I think they look at would
look at what's happening in Texas and
say you know the system is working at
every level you have local leadership
you have state leadership governor
Scott's getting great marks for being an
act again he's an entrepreneur like
Trump and you have federal leadership
with President Trump and it's all
pulling in the same direction and I
think that's what's encouraging the
people after all this gridlock all this
nastiness all these vicious stories here
you have the American government coming
together in the American people coming
together in a positive way
let me I've been very outspoken and
disappointed about the Republicans not
keeping their promises from my
perspective and you know having been
speaker and having accomplished a lot of
speaker I would argue that they have 14
weeks to really get their act together
and that would include changing the tax
code 7 brackets 2/3 repatriated money
from multinationals trillions corporate
cuts middle-class tax cuts small
business cuts energy independence build
the wall I'm not that overly optimistic
these guys are going to get their job
done what are your thoughts well I'm
moderately optimistic particularly on
what I think is the biggest assignment
and I really like what secretary
manuchehr has been saying in his various
television news I like very much what
Speaker Paul Ryan said today in an
interview or a press conference I guess
it was their commitment is to get all
this done
hopefully by Thanksgiving to be able to
give the American people as minuchin
described it yesterday a tax form about
the size of a large postcard for the
average American I think they can pull
that off if they can get to a 15%
corporate rate if they can get to a
bigger bigger tax cut for small business
you're really good this will be the
Chipman if I were them I would I would
mark every week against getting the tax
cut done we can get everything else done
once the tax cuts done but let's get it
signed by Thanksgiving so that the first
quarter of next year you see a real
surge of economic growth probably
starting frankly with the Christmas
period because the people see a big tax
cut coming you're going to have a pretty
big Christmas in this country yeah you
know I had a front row seat to your
ascendancy to become Speaker I was a
local radio guy in Atlanta and I was
seen the night he became speaker but
prior to that you had created a series
it was called renewing American
civilization it really was the
foundation of ideas and solutions to
make the country better and I always
argue that people ask me I say you
professor and a historian at heart not a
politician because I've known you you
know these couple of decades you now
basically are starting that role up
again with defending America real quick
to tell us how people can join that
class of yours well all them to just go
to defending America course.com
it's a phase one is going to be six
sessions it's really on how to defeat
the left intellectually the arguments
that allow us to remind people why
America is unique why American history
matters and why being patriotic is
important I think people will find that
defending America calm has some
Americans I'm sorry defending America of
course calm has some very very good
ideas in it and you're right it's part
of something I used to do I believe in
teaching and I believe in an informed
citizenry all right and we'll put it up
on Hannity comm my website mr. speaker
thanks for being with us we appreciate
it